this Saturday Sports Illustrated will
reveal the cover model for their
swimsuit issue as part of a TNT special
but camera and joins us once again with
some amazing women who are making news
inside the pages of that issue cam Nancy
let me tell you something they're
breaking the stereotypical mold of the
magazine and only I talked to plus-size
model Ashley Graham who just found out
she is an official Sports Illustrated
model now Ashley is also part of a new
ad campaign in the magazine proving
bikini bodies come in all shapes and
sizes I'm really excited to know that
Sports Illustrated is wanting to include
women like us there is no perfect body
and that we shouldn't be striving for
perfection anymore 5 foot 9 in a size 14
to 16
Ashley's also repping swimsuits for all
alongside other models who are
redefining beauty when did that change
when did all of a sudden you realize I
am going to be wearing bikinis I am a
swimsuit model this is my first big
swimsuit job so I run on settlements the
fitting and they showed you this gold
bikini I was like me ha ha it's
incredibly empowering it's it's like a
new era we're now seeing different races
different shapes different sizes being
celebrated as beautiful the campaign is
also taking on ageism Nicola Griffin is
a sexy 56 years old I've never worn a
bikini before never thought I could I
would look good in one and ever felt
sexy one but I was wrong I'd love to
know in your modeling careers if you
ever received the feedback that you
didn't have the right body type to wear
a bikini I had an agent one time wave
money in my face and say honey if you
lost a bunch of those lbs you'd be
getting a lot more of this and honey
these 5/16 hips they have made me a lot
of besra inspiring stuff I could have
talked to them all day now Ashley and
the ladies will reach a wide audience
with their message last year's from suit
issue reached 70 million people in the
US alone
Manzi one important thing to talk about
thank you very much Cameron
you